new zealand is divided over the
all-white name change you seen this
no
a heated debate is raging in new zealand
after the country's football governing
body said it was considering changing
the nickname of the men's national team
new zealand football has revealed that
the all-white name could be changed in
order to avoid racist connotations
the sports governing body has confirmed
that it was reviewing the name setting
the scene for arguments between the old
school traditionalists and those who
value inclusivity many new zealand
sporting sides have colour based
nicknames the men's cricket side are the
black caps the men's basketball side are
the tall blacks however non-rankle like
the all-whites which can be read to mean
excluding other ethnicities the question
of the name change comes as many new
zealand organizations adopt names and
identities that incorporate maori
culture and language the police chief
sorry the police chief football chief
said that the
sporting body was on a journey around
cultural inclusivity we are working on a
process with stakeholders across the
game as well as people from outside
football looking at all areas of the
organization to make sure they are fit
for purpose in 2021 and beyond
uh one of new zealand's greatest ever
players wynton roofer a proud maori man
and a member of the 1982 team that they
got their
name from said changing the all white's
name was quote absolute madness the all
blacks brand is iconic and this is no
different
okay so this is the first time i've ever
heard of the name the all whites me too
i don't think new zealand are
particularly good at football
right so that's what i was like the
always what i know the all blacks
because they're
legendary literally one of the greatest
dynasties in all of sport um
you know there's been a lot of changes
in america with american football
um
with
many other teams in their logos um and
it's just redskins and stuff yeah the
redskins now i don't know what they're
this is pathetic but i think they're
just like the washington football team
or something like that that's what the
best name ever yeah yeah um and then you
know the indians had that old logo which
was like the smiling native american guy
the newest name is the washington
football team
yeah is that is that what it is the
washington football team yep so then um
it also was the bullets they were
chained that was changed in
god maybe the late 90s
2000 maybe what did that original mean
the bullets it was the washington
bullets and it was just a bullet logo it
was cool
violence crime violence okay so so then
now they're the uh washington wizards
it's a basketball team
um there's plenty of different things
like that and
i don't know it can be argued both ways
a red skin is pretty tough man it's hard
to
you know that is a slang
that is a slang term that's a derogatory
term um
but it depends you know who are you
offending and are they offended and
that's the real question the question
would be whether or not an all whites
versus an all blacks and a black caps
and a tall blacks
like that's this is the theme that new
zealand have going between all of their
different sports teams all blacks the
rugby and if you change one you got to
change them all right
well no by that logic there's an
inherent punching up versus punching
down
like perspective that's being used that
somehow all blacks is inclusive but all
whites isn't and
i don't know man it just feels like
can we not try
to keep
race dynamics
out of
sport as much as possible i'm aware that
sport is a good opportunity to display
to people like look
this is a a very diverse team that we
have on the field and this is a young
working-class
asian guy white guy black guy whatever
guy that comes up through the ranks and
you can be like that person like
individual players and their teams at
large are awesome role models for young
kids and for older people as well
but
like when you've got an entire country's
set of sporting teams named after the
tall blacks and the black caps and the
all blacks like the all-whites being the
one that gets singled out
it sounds like men over the age of 40
should be getting vasectomies it just
sounds like
that again
it's as ridiculous in your mind
maybe not quite but it's obviously
it's obviously stupid
like to to do that
highlights and asymmetry
right
yeah no i mean that's what i was saying
is is if if they
determine that one is bad they have to
determine all of them are bad because
they're all along the same line
right all of the the all whites the tall
blacks the blacks
you know
it's
what is
would they be playing
i don't know what are short people good
at
wrestling i think okay
yeah so the
new zealand wrestling the short blacks
or the short whites yeah
yeah yeah i i honestly that's the first
time i've ever heard of the all whites
well no sure now you've heard of it
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace